I want to start with CPAC today, the Conservative
Political Action Conference holding their first
2023 event starting Wednesday, March 1st.
Now, I was particularly interested in this
CPAC because it was going to allow us to see
what is going to be the approach of this group
to the 2024 primary at this early stage where
Donald Trump is still in command, we have to
admit. But there is a fracturing and there are
different elements of the right, some of which
like the idea of more Trump and some of which are
decidedly anti-Trump. And then organizations like
Fox News were sort of saying, well, we'd rather
someone else, but we're not going to completely
abandoned Trump. We're going to wait and see what
would be the mood at CPAC because of all of these
different speakers giving us a window into the
talking points that would be applied to the
2024 primary? Or hypothetically, might the CPAC
speakers just ignore the 2024 primary as if it's
not going on, sort of ignoring it like an elephant
in the room that nobody wants to talk about? Well,
we are still going to be able to see, but it
is going to be with a much diminished audience
and fewer Republican insiders. And the background
of all of this is that a guy named Matt SCHLAPP,
who is not exactly a beacon of gay rights, has
been credibly accused of what's the right word,
at minimum, sexual harassment. And I believe it is
accurate to say sexual assault of a male staffer
some months ago. And it is believed that this is
sort of the black cloud over the head of CPAC.
So let's look at a couple of different articles
explaining what's going on. First and foremost,
CPAC is being ignored by Fox News. One
of the biggest outlets for CPAC getting
attention is that Fox News covers the event,
interviews people there, promotes the event,
etc.. Daily Beast Right. CPAC has a major Fox
News problem after right wing powerbroker Matt
SCHLAPP was accused of sexual assault. He and
his annual confab have all but disappeared
from Fox News. A shocking break from years past
and it is a breakthrough. Shocking. You know,
it's sort of subjective, but it is certainly
a break amid the alleged groping scandal.
Justin Barragan for The Daily Beast writes Over
the past few years, the conservative cable giant
has not only aired the entire multi-day conference
on its digital streaming platform, Fox Nation,
but the network has also been a featuring sponsor.
In 2021, for example, Fox Nation paid a quarter
of $1,000,000 to help underwrite the overtly
partizan gathering. The year before that, they
paid $28,000 to be a sponsor as of publication,
SCHLAPP and his annual convention have all but
disappeared from the Fox News universe. None of
Fox media outlets are listed among their sponsors,
which includes their conservative arch rival,
Newsmax, as well as far right competitors like
Real America's Voice. Additionally, Fox staffers
told The Daily Beast they have yet to receive any
guidance on how they will cover CPAC. An apparent
Fox News blackout on CPAC would present a stunning
break from past years, which reliably demonstrated
a symbiosis between the cable giant and the
right wing confab. HANNITY and Laura Ingraham
would often deliver speeches or host panels,
which then the network carried. And then outside
the ballroom, you would see FOX people walking
around. It's not clear whether any of that will
be going on. Now, the context does seem to be
the alleged groping scandal that I. There was
some speculation that this break between Fox
News and CPAC has more to do with Trump than
it has to do with the groping scandal. Maybe,
but I have not seen any actual evidence of that.
And the Daily Beast article does mention The Daily
Beast first reported that SCHLAPP allegedly groped
the crotch of a male staffer on failed Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker's campaign. The
individual. This is insane that this is this is
the language that's being used. Claimed that Matt
SCHLAPP graphed his, quote, junk and these terms
are all in quotes and pummeled it at length and
it was scarring and humiliating. SCHLAPP is just
denying he's acknowledged didn't happen, even
though there are text messages that do seem to
show. SCHLAPP Uncomfortable and and maybe I don't
want to say apologetic but regretful in some way.
SCHLAPP is, as far as we know, heterosexual
and married to a woman. So that is part of the
problem that CPAC is having. Now, there is another
story with this. Mike Pence declines invitation
to CPAC as events Leader Comes under fire. This
is from ABC News. The decision by Pence. Sue
is debating a 2024 presidential run rights. ABC
News comes as other notable figures are absent.